[Musique]
et voilà l'heure du panel a sonné ils
ont gracieusement accepté de nous faire
part de leurs impressions sur les
événements de la semaine et de la
journée émilie nicolas hugo lavallée
christian du four bonsoir à vous trois
sans grande surprise le dossier du
troisième lien est encore bien présent
dans cette campagne mais aujourd'hui il
a refait surface en ce sixième jour par
le biais des propos du candidat vedette
de la caq dans les vies bernard
drainville qui s'élance et je dirais
dans une vigoureuse défense de ce projet
phare au 9 centimes sur un ville piqué
au vif par les nombreuses questions sur
l'impact d'un éventuel troisième ligne
sur les mici démission à gaz à effet de
serre on va écouter monsieur rainville
dans un premier temps ensuite la
réaction de gabriel nadeau dubois et vos
impressions
puis d'accord ça prend des études mais
je veux dire un affaires
l'attendent convient là a pas besoin
d'être étudiée de juste besoin dans ton
char dans le trafic puis tu la vie
l'amour et attentes lors chez moi avec
les gms ça va être de plus en plus des
véhicules électriques qui vont rouler
dans le troisième ligne quand ils vont
être construits
c'est une patente à gosses électorale
inventé par la cac
ça ne tient pas la route c'est ridicule
ce projet là ne vaut même pas le papier
sur lequel les flyers de la caq sont
imprimés
diamétralement opposé ces deux visions
celle de monsieur nadeau dubois et
bernard drainville commençons avec vous
la vallée parce que le contexte est
important et certains ont dit
aujourd'hui basse et du bernard
drainville pur jugera oui aujourd'hui on
le retrouvait vraiment le bernard
drainville qu'on connaissait bien
l'assemblée nationale à l'époque où il
était au parti québécois qui me suivre
un fil qui était très en forme qui a
vraiment essayé de se dépeindre comme
celui qui défend les gens de lévis
contre ce ailleurs au québec qui sont
nombreux qui ont des réserves sur ce
projet de troisième bien le problème
c'est que monsieur drevet le peut-être
marqué des points dans sa
circonscription auprès des électeurs de
lévis aujourd'hui c'est moins sûr qu'il
veut vraiment aider son parti pourquoi
parce que si le troisièmee impopulaire à
lévis et pas nécessairement le cas
partout au québec d'une part et d'autre
part il est venu donner des arguments
justement n'est bien entendu la réplique
de gabriel nadeau-dubois donc des
arguments tous ceux qui ont des doutes
sur les vertus environnementales de la
caq on sait que monsieur legault a été
en rattrapage sur cette question là
durant une bonne partie de son mandat
ils essaient maintenant de nous dire que
l'environnement c'est une priorité avec
ce genre de déclaration là ça peut
soulever un doute sacré en tout cas une
ambiguïté et monsieur dans la ville est
assez habile y connaît bien les médias
c'est bien là que cette phrase largement
avec les gps ça va être repris par les
adversaires ça va être repris un peu
partout va recevoir des mines sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est sûrement déjà le
cas effectivement même si en plus c'est
bon on comprend il ajouté par la suite
il parlait des véhicules électriques les
seuls comptes exacts mais cette courte
phrase lâchée montée jeu est ça risque
bien de rester et me dit mais je pense
que quand on quand on analyse une
campagne mais la première chose que je
regarde c'est l'effet c'est vrai que le
monde poney dans le graphique lorsqu'il
est question de traverser le québec
québec peu près tous les experts sur la
question sont par contre d'accord pour
dire que quand on rajoute des des voix
pour circuler on rajoute aussi des autos
les gens vont plus loin ont contribué à
l'étalement urbain donc quelques années
plus tard les gens
comme le disent monsieur dray ville
centre qui sont plus d'autres
trafiquants fils qui dit pas c'est que
dans cinq ans plus tard il ya encore ce
risque là des plus de trafic que
plusieurs experts ont déjà dit à ce
niveau là est la deuxième chose c'est
que au niveau des voitures des voitures
électriques c'est quelque chose qui
polluent énormément à construire plus
que les voitures normales donc ça prend
en fait plusieurs dizaines de milliers
kilomètres avant d'arriver à quelque
chose qui polluent moins sucré moins tu
es donc factuellement ce qui dit je
comprends leur
envie de faire de la communication au
style qui est très effectivement proches
lorsqu'il était au parti québécois mais
en fait moi j'avance je sentais
l'animateur de radio aussi dans son ton
mais en fait quand vous dites des choses
comme si nécessairement on ouvre aussi
la voie à se faire en fait voici les
faits par rapport à la déclaration je
pas sûr que ça aide électoralement de
dire des choses qui qui sont si faciles
à vérifier ou d'un point de vue factuel
question
ouest au passage obligé pour ceux qui
joignent la caq comme martin biron
bernard prévu de rentrer de leur appui
au 3 juillet d'autant que les deux et
martin biron et bien l'adresse ville
sont quand même dans la région au québec
et puis mets l'accent là dessus et donc
lui c'est concret et moi je vois dire
que moi ça me touche parce que moi j'ai
plus de discuter avec le fait que le
dossier soit devenue nationale parce
qu'il me semble que quand tu vis dans la
région de québec où tu vécu autant de la
région de québec tony est un
projet aussi des considérations
théoriques ou idéologiques quand tu vis
dans un endroit je trouve qu'il est
mieux placé pour prendre une décision
que ce que j'ai appris quelque chose en
fait parce que ça déclarait souhaiter à
seyssuel on l'a appris que bientôt les
autos serait électrique savait moins
d'impact sur les gaz à effet de serre
jamais jamais entendu parler de cet
argument donc on enregistre saut dans
notre pays mais moi je rappelle que
c'est quand même une tragédie que pour
un grand projet collectif comme ça il
n'y a pas plus de consensus dans la
région de québec et moi j'insiste moi là
dessus une simple c'est plus aux gens de
québec d'avoir une opinion là dessus que
tous les québécois qui connaissent pas
grand chose noble en allumant les eaux
sont défendus qui engage tous les
contribuables son effort public est
resté jusqu'au bout et je sais mais
c'est quand même nous et c'est
l'environnement et cela nous concerne
tous
oui mais c'est avant tout un dossier
concerne la région de québec et c'est un
dossier en fait michael monsieur legault
s'est pas engagé politiquement c'est
très difficile pour lui de reculer mais
je trouve ça un beau gâchis tout ça pour
de tous parce que normalement les grands
projets c'est stimulant faut qu'elle
plus de consensus il ya actuellement et
a marqué quand on a surtout parlé de ça
aujourd'hui hugo lavallée c'est comme
s'il avait perdu tellement l'expression
voix l'échoppé est temps de révéler tous
les autres engagements qui ont été mis
de l'avant par son propre parti aussi
oui effectivement essayé une autre des
raisons pour laquelle je pas certain
qu'ils aient rendu service à la cac
aujourd'hui parce que effectivement
s'ajouter dans l'ombre cette promesse en
matière de santé qui était quand même
intéressante on veut créer une nouvelle
application où on va pouvoir faire plus
facilement prendre des rendez vous
auprès de médecins ou d'autres
professionnels de la santé on en a
pratiquement pas parlé aujourd'hui par
rapport à ce que vous dit christian tout
à l'heure effectivement c'est dommage de
voir qu'un grand projet comme celui là
soit fassent pas l'objet d'un consensus
plus large par contre c'est inévitable
que tout le reste du québec s'intéresse
à ce projet là on investit tellement
d'argent dans ce projet là ici aussi que
ça nous en dit beaucoup sur la vision du
gouvernement la vision du développement
urbain par exemple la place qu'il
accorde à l'environnement justement à la
lutte aux gaz à effet de serre c'est un
peu inévitable ça devienne un enjeu
national même si effectivement ça
concerne d'abord les gens de québec et
me dis qu'est-ce que ça ne nous envoient
aussi comme message sur le type des
lecteurs un don peut en guinée se passer
la caq avec ce genre de message
c'est sûr que en période électorale on
se concentre surtout sur les comptes et
qu'ils sont sur un puits les comptes et
les quotas dans les comics sont pas sur
les côtés qui sont des contes etc sont
décomptés pivot il y en a beaucoup dans
la région québec y en a aussi beaucoup
dans la banlieue de montréal et c'est
souvent dans ces régions le québec et la
région québec les 4 5 0 que les messages
électorales sont concentrés ça veut dire
que des électeurs dans les comics sont
déjà très très caquistes que si la sig
et des déclarations qui sont faites pour
la ville de québec qui fait descendre de
5% 10% 2% le vote le vote la caisse dans
ces régions là en fait ça change pas le
nombre de députés au total lorsqu'il ya
des lorsqu'il ya des côtés qui sont très
sûrs donc je pense que c'est quelque
chose qu'on s'est habitué beaucoup à
voir au fédéral de du micro marketing au
niveau des campagnes électorales je
pense que dans un cas comme ça on va
avoir aussi de plus en plus au québec on
cite des régions précises et des enjeux
précis puis pour le reste on se dit que
on va cibler ses autres régions la plus
tard avec des mets faire que mon père
est aussi fort puis qui vont peut-être
plus se concentrer son camp de plus
toutes les quand on parle des autres
semblent être dans l'air du temps
d'aller des moeurs politiques de
l'époque maintenant j'aimerais qu'on
parle de l'autre aspect dominant à
prédominance cette semaine qui s'est
décliné au fil des derniers jours la
violence envers les élus qui hier s'est
mutée en session de haut on se montrait
du doigt les uns des autres on chercher
les coupables de ce climat toxique dans
lequel on se trouve bref parlons du ton
de la campagne jusqu'à présent je
comprends qu'il ya des éléments externes
qui viennent des personnes est un peu
tout ça mais on va commencer par écouter
ensemble éric duhaime aujourd'hui qui
vous me direz si vous trouvez que son
temps avaient changé c'est rhétorique
avait changé sur ce même en jeu lui qui
était pris pour cible par notamment le
parti libéral et marwa risky hier
écoutons éric duhaime aujourd'hui
je veux d'abord pour une troisième
journée consécutive
lancé un appel au calme et condamné les
manifestations de violence de toute
forme de sympathisants de tous les
partis
incluant les conservateurs
question comment vous interpréter le
message le temps la forme
[Musique]
pour effectuer
quelques
semaines ça arrive très tôt arrivera tôt
ou tard parce qu'eric d'homme c'est
l'élément nouveau qui menace sa veste
paysage politique autant j'ai eu de la
sympathie pour un bavoir vite si donc au
sujet de sa sagesse des menaces qui lui
ont été adressés et puis fait qu'elle
soit enceinte autant ça a dérapé par
monsieur c'est pas éric duhaime qui est
responsable de ce qui est arrivé à
maroua outil absolument pas puis quand
il dit qu'il veut faire entrer la grogne
au parlement ne rien de répréhensible à
diop la grogne c'est une super
mécontentement regarder dans le
dictionnaire mais ça permet à eric jean
m en fait qu'un potentiel d'électeurs
important parce que y'a pas juste et
complotisme sont susceptibles de voter
pour lui il ya tous ceux qui avec le
recul trouve que dans la gestion de la
crise inter cet avis trop loin qu'on
astral passe à 6 et des gens qu'on a
méprisé des méridiens il faut que je
fasse très
parce que pas droit à l'erreur la
culture politique québécoise est
tempérée modérés et les ports a dit
qu'alors lui est associé quand même un
cultures politiques radicales il peut
avoir un temps non je pense que pour lui
c'est important qu'ils incorporent ce
message lourd mais cette semaine j'ai
trouvé qu'à une mauvaise foi l'égard des
rituels
est allé trop loin comme si c'était lui
qui était responsable de guitton de la
violence c'est pas vrai on peut
évidemment remonter très loin l'époque
était à la radio x mais reste que c'est
pas quelqu'un qui a approuvé la violence
qui l'encouragé mais pour lui c'est une
bonne chose sa déclaration d'aujourd'hui
de mettre les pendules à l'heure parce
que on lui pardonne pas le système
politico-médiatique en fait est
profondément contre
quant au discours médiatique contre
d'aller les chroniqueurs l'aider
d'analysé très peu de jal qui dépend des
rituels faut quand même être franc je
dois donc à ce moment là il faut que lui
et ne pas le droit à l'erreur sur ce
thème là et cette semaine je le rappelle
on était juste sont déroulés talitres
eux même ridicule la personne qui
l'agressé savait rien à voir avec les
rituels me rappelle faire entrer la
grogne à la sabine rue il faut la faire
rentrer la grogne à l'assemblée
nationale 6 un autocar est dans la rue
et la grogne c'est pas de la violence
désolé hugo avait il senti vous qui
amène pression pour se ré ridge m parce
qu'on a senti que son appel au calme
aujourd'hui et est d'un autre ordre
oui effectivement on a vu qu'il a voulu
aller un peu plus loin que là où il
était allé jusqu'à présent la seule
bonne nouvelle dans tout ça cette
semaine c'est probablement effectivement
qu'il ya eu cet appel au calme de façon
plus générale à l'échelle de tous les
partis on a senti donc qu'il y avait un
sentiment d'unité face à cette hostilité
qui s'expriment face à tous les
candidats à tous les partis beaucoup
d'excès dans les médias sociaux on le
voit des menaces ce cambriolage aussi
donc véritablement le fait qu'il ya eu
cet appel au calme ça nous dit quand
même qu'on est capable parfois justement
si les chefs de partis font les efforts
nécessaires d'aller au delà des lignes
de parti sa pas été parfait
effectivement hier ça s'est échauffé un
peu mais aujourd'hui on a senti une
tentative de remettre les choses en
perspective
l'autre chose aussi qui est intéressant
de vous l'avez souligné d'entrée de jeu
ce sont des facteurs externes qui amène
cette discussion sur le ton c'est pas un
chef qui en a accusé un hôte de manière
très très abrasives ait pas eu
d'attaqués personnelles en fait le ton
entre les chefs de partis depuis le
début de la campagne est assez serein
malgré tout ce qui est quand même assez
positif il ya eu des campagnes au québec
où ça n'a pas toujours été le cas
rappelez vous en 2012 par exemple entre
madame marois monsieur charest on sa
cuisine de corruption monsieur charest
disait avec madame marois c'est le
référendum et la rue donc des attaques
très dures jusqu'à présent dans cette
campagne en ce qui concerne entre les
acteurs politiques eux mêmes le ton a
été quand même assez modérée pour le
souligner est vide et j'aimerais vous
entendre sur éric duhaime et la
réflexion de christian je présume que
vous êtes de prêtres d'accord avec cette
interprétation qu'on le traite
injustement quel est votre regard
là-dessus ce week-end monsieur jam mais
au sens large aussi le climat social
actuel au québec ça vous inquiète
ben serein que jamais comme tel je
souriais quand on disait que c'était
quelqu'un qui avait le système politico
médiatique contre lui alors que c'est un
produit du système politico médiatique
c'est quelqu'un qui a été conseiller
politique pour 36 trop combien de partis
politiques et c'est quelqu'un qui a fait
son nom à la radio et son parti et est
soutenue par les radios privées à québec
qui lui ont donné 20 des entrevues c'est
notamment à cause de l'écosystème
médiatique à québec on peut expliquer
une partie de montée du parti
conservateur dans la région là bas ceci
dit je pense que effectivement les tons
le ton des échanges a été plus posée à
québec cette hausse durant la campagne
interne province âge jusqu'à présent et
je pense notamment à cause de ce qui se
passe au fédéral je pense que celle
éléments de contexte on fait qu' en
france et dans l'équation avec la
campagne de pierre polie f poilievre qui
se fait notamment accusés de contribuer
à des attaques envers des journalistes à
un ton très acrimonieux
la campagne est bien politique et pris
beaucoup de temps à condamner ce qui
s'est passé avec le circuit rennes au
début de la semaine aussi maxime bernier
qui sont les médias sociaux eu un ton
excessivement acrimonieux même partager
les
coordonnées des journalistes pour
diriger ses militants sur ces
journalistes là il ya quelque chose qui
se passe au fédéral et le québec n'est
pas dans un vase clos nécessairement ça
a un impact sur la façon dont on fait
attention aux mots au québec est
nécessairement ericsson qui a d'ailleurs
eu l'appui officiellement de maxime
bernier fait partie de cet écosystème là
c'est un ancien aussi conseiller du
parti conservateur fédéral donc il ya
cette pression-là sur lui de dire moi je
suis différent de ce qui se passe en ce
moment fédéral et je pense que c'est ce
qui se joue en trame de fond les choix
de mon d'eric j'aime cette semaine et
permettez je trouve que le québec le
suédois est une société distincte on
n'est pas les états unis n'est pas le
club anglais est dans le fait qu'on
s'est mis cette semaine a parlé des
différentes parties politiques tchèques
ont évacué d'éléments importants qui
popent politique c'est la révolution
numérique c'est les réseaux sociaux
depuis que tout un chacun peut donner
son opinion en fait sa petite tribune
beaucoup moins de tous en sus avant les
gens pensaient delicious qui était
méchante mais ne le disait pas il ne
l'est pas à ce moment là tout le monde
dit n'importe quoi sur les réseaux
sociaux d'ailleurs s'ils attaquent cette
semaine quand on dit que telle et menace
celle faite sur les réseaux sociaux et
ça c'est au delà de la politique au delà
de la gauche droite et enfin une
campagne électorale c'est normal que ça
s'échauffe un peu et c'est pour ça que
c'est délicat parce que là il incombe à
des débats d'idées qu'elle sa mairie que
tu m'aimes ne fait pas il fait pas
l'unanimité il ya des gens qu'ils aiment
vraiment pas donc comment commencer vu
l'aspect combats ont été nécessaires
sans que ça dérape donc cette semaine
moi je c'est un bien pour cible parce
que le débat a eu lieu iridium je pense
qu'un message que construit au pôle
droit l'air et quant aux autres je
trouve qu'ils ont été un peu trop bien
pensants faudrait que le contrat d'éric
duhaime représente quelque chose que sa
place dans le paysage politique même si
beaucoup de gens qui veulent ils
risquent dans cette joute politique
c'est de perdre de vue diront certains
les enjeux comme tel qui concerne les
québécois leur présent et leur avenir
hugo en terminant ya peut-être un aspect
à surveiller au cours des prochains
jours c'est le premier grand rendez vous
électoral cinq chefs une élection mes
collègues patrie soit anne marie
dussault céline galipeau qui vont en
direct questionner chacun des cinq chefs
ça peut donner un nouvel élan un nouveau
ton reprenons justement ce terme à cette
campagne et être recentré tout ça sur
certains enjeux clés n'est ce pas où est
probablement en tout cas espérons leur
revenir sur le fond plutôt que sur la
forme évidemment c'est pas un débat ça
peut-être pas le même potentiel de lire
en page locale qu'un débat des chefs par
contre on a vu l'exercice au fédéral
savait était utile ce avait mis en
relief quand même des contrastes assez
intéressante avec les chefs donc ça va
être à surveiller ce dimanche la
première fois où ils vont être bons à
défaut d'être ensemble réunit sur un
même plateau où ils vont être à tout le
moins dans la même émission on va
pouvoir comparer contrastée parce qu'il
faut dire que jusqu'à maintenant il ya
beaucoup d'engagement des gens disent
amen et c'est pas toujours évident si
des mairies puisque beaucoup
d'engagement qui se ressemblent d'un
parti allait très bien ce sera surveillé
envoyé ici des photos des préparatifs
patrice est dans les parages se prépare
de façon très méthodique comme on le
connaît il sera prêt tout comme mes
collègues emilie christian hugo je vous
remercie pour cette précieuse
participation à ces panels en vous
souhaitant une belle fin de semaine
reposez vous bien merci à vous aussi
merci